جميعنا نعرف جيدا هذه الصوره وجميعنا كان
يعتقد انها مرسومه ببرامج التصميم
المفاجاه في صوره سطح المكتب في نظام
ويندوز اكس بي الذي استخدمناه لسنوات
طويله انها حقيقيه وتم التقاطها بالصدفه
لاحقا عرفت بصوره النعيم صاحب هذه الصوره
هو المصور تشارلز اورير الذي كان متوجها
الى منطقه تسوناما في طريقه لولايته
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه لاحظ هذا المنظر
الساحر فاخرج الكاميرا والتقط هذا المشهد
الحقيقي تماما وقتها لم يكن تشارلز يعلم
ان صورته ستصبح الاكثر شهره فقد بلغ عدد
الحواسيب التي بعتب هذا النظام ازيد من
مليار نسخه ما يعني ان الصوره تشاهدها
اكثر من مليار شخص على اقل تقدير وهي ثاني
اغلى صوره في العالم حسب ما سرحت به
الشركه
[موسيقى]